you
have created one of the most
popular programming languages in the
world
this is the programming language that i
first learned
about object-oriented programming with
you know i think it's a programming
language that
a lot of people use in a lot of
different places and millions of devices
today
java so the
absurd question but can you tell
the origin story of java so
a long time ago at sun in about 1990
there was a
group of us who
were kind of worried that there was
stuff going on
in the universe of computing that the
computing industry was missing out on
um and
so uh a few of us started this project
at sun
that really got going i mean we started
talking about it in 1990 and it really
got going in 91
and it was all about
you know what was happening in terms of
you know computing hardware you know
processors and
networking and all of that that was
outside of the computer industry and
that was
everything from the the
the these sort of early glimmers of cell
phones that were happening then
to you know you look at elevators and
locomotives and process control systems
in
factories and all kinds of audio
audio equipment and video equipment
they all had processors in them and they
were all doing stuff with them
and and it and it sort of felt like
there was something going on there that
we needed to understand
and so c c and c plus plus was in the
air
already oh no c and c plus plus
absolutely owned the universe at that
time
everything was written in c and z plus
plus so where was the hunch that there
was a need for a revolution
well so the the need for a revolution
was not about
the lang a language it was about
it was just as simple and vague as
there are things happening out there
and we understand them we need to
understand them
and and so um
a few of us went on several
um somewhat epic road trips
um literal road trips literal road trips
it's like get on an airplane
go to japan visit you know
toshiba and sharp and mitsubishi and
sony and all of these folks and
you know because we worked for sun we
had you know folks who were willing to
like give us introductions you know we
we visited you know samsung and um
you know a bunch of korean companies and
we went all over europe we went to you
know
places like like phillips and siemens
and thompson
and what did you see there
you know for me the one of the things
that sort of left out
was that they were doing all the usual
computer
computer things that people had been
doing like 20 years before
the thing that really left out to me was
that they were
sort of reinventing computer networking
and they were making
all the mistakes that people in the
computer industry
had had made and since i had been doing
a lot of work in
in the networking area you know you know
we'd go and
you know visit you know company x they'd
describe
this networking thing that they were
doing and just without any thought i
could i could tell them like the 25
things
that were going to be complete disasters
with that thing that they were doing
um and i don't know whether that had any
impact on any of them but but but that
particular story of
you know sort of repeating the disasters
of the computer science industry um
was there and we and one of the things
we thought was
well maybe we could do something useful
here with like
bringing them forward somewhat but but
also
at the same time we learned a bunch of
things
from from these you know mostly consumer
electronics companies
um and
you know high on the list was that
they viewed their like relationship with
the customer as sacred
um they they were never
ever willing to make
trade-offs between
for for safety right so
one of the things that had always made
me
nervous in the computer industry
was that um
people were willing to make trade-offs
in reliability
to get performance um
you know the the you know they they want
faster faster it breaks a little more
often because it's fast you know you
maybe you run it a little hotter than
you should or
like like the one that always blew my
mind was the way that
um the folks at at cray supercomputers
got their division to be really fast
was that they did newton-raphson
approximations
and so you know the bottom several bits
you know a over b we're essentially
random numbers
um what could possibly go wrong what
could go wrong
right and you know
just figuring out how to nail the bottom
bit
um how to make sure that you know
if you put a piece of toast in a toaster
it's not going to kill the customer
it's not going to burst into flames and
burn the house down
so those are i guess those are the the
principles that were inspiring
but how did from the days of uh
java is called oak because of a tree
outside the window story that a lot of
people know how did it become this
incredible
like powerful language
well so it was a bunch of things so we
you know after all that we started you
know the way that we decided that we
could
understand things better was by
building a demo building a prototype of
something
okay so um kind of because it was easy
and fun we decided to build
a control system for some home
electronics you know tv vcr that kind of
stuff
and as we were building it we you know
we we sort of discovered that there were
some things
about standard practice in c programming
that um were really getting in the way
and it wasn't it wasn't exactly you know
because we were
writing this all the c code and c plus
plus code
that that we couldn't write it to do the
right thing
but that um one of the things that was
weird in the group was that we had um
a guy who's who's who's
you know his sort of top-level job was
he was a business guy
you know he was sort of an mba kind of
person
you know think about business plans and
all of that and
you know there were a bunch of things
that were kind of
you know and we would talk about things
that were going wrong and
or things were going wrong things were
going right and
you know as we thought about you know
things like like their requirements for
security and safety um
some low-level details and see like
naked pointers
yeah and you know
so so back in the early 90s
um it was well understood
that you know the number one source of
like security vulnerabilities is
pointers was just pointers was just bugs
yeah right and it was like you know
50 60 70 of all security
vulnerabilities were bugs and the vast
majority of them were like
buffer overflows yeah so you're like
we have to fix this we have to make sure
that this
cannot happen and that was kind of the
original
thing for me was this cannot this cannot
continue
and one of the things i find really
entertaining this year was um
i forget which rag published it but
there was this article that came out
that was um an examination
it was sort of the result of of an
examination of all the security
vulnerabilities in chrome and chrome is
like a giant piece of c
plus plus code and 60 or 70 percent of
all the security
vulnerabilities were stupid pointer
tricks
and i thought it's 30 years later
and we're still there still there and
we're still there
and you know i you know that's one of
those you know
slap your forehead and and and just
just just want to cry would you
attribute
uh or is that too much of a
simplification but would you attribute
the creation of java to uh
[Laughter]
to see pointers um obvious problem well
i mean that was that was one of the the
trigger points
and currency you've mentioned
concurrency was a big deal
um yeah you know because when you're
interacting with people you know the
last thing you ever want to see
is is the thing like waiting
and you know issues about
the software development process you
know when faults happen
can you recover from them what can you
do
to make it easier to create and
eliminate complex data structures
what can you do to fix you know the one
of the most common
sea problems which is storage leaks
um and it's it's evil twin the
um the the freed but
still being used piece of piece of
memory you know you you free something
and then you keep using it oh yeah
you know so so when i was originally
thinking about that i was thinking about
it in terms of
of sort of safety and security issues
and one of the things i sort of came to
believe
came to understand was that it wasn't
just about safety and security but it
was about
um developer velocity
right so and i got really religious
about this because
at that point i had spent an ungodly
amount of my life
hunting down mystery pointer bugs
and you know like like two-thirds of my
time
as a software developer was you know
because the mystery pointer bugs tend to
be
the hardest to find because they tend to
be
very very statistical the ones that hurt
you know their you know they're like a
one in a million chance
um and
but nevertheless create an infinite
amount of suffering right
because when you're doing a billion
operations a second
yeah you know i'm one in a million
chance means
it's gonna happen um
and and so i got really religious about
this thing about you know making it so
that if something fails
it fails immediately and visibly
and you know one of the
the the things that was a a real
attraction of java to lots of
development shops was that
you know we get our code up and running
twice as fast you mean like the entirety
of the development
process the blocking all that kind of
stuff yeah if you you know so so if you
measure
time from you know you you first
touch fingers to keyboard until you get
your first demo out
not much different but if you look from
fingers touching keyboard to
solid piece of software that you could
release in production
it would be way faster and i think what
people don't often realize there's
yeah there's things that really slow you
down like
hard to catch bugs probably is
is the thing that really slows down that
is it really slows things down
but but also there were you know one of
the things that you get
out of object oriented programming is a
strict methodology about you know what
are the interfaces between things
and being really clear about how
parts relate to each other
and what that helps with is
so many times what people do
is they kind of like sneak around the
side so if you've built something
and people are using it and then
and you say and you say well okay you
know i built this thing
you use it this way and then you
change it in such a way that that it
still does what you said it does it just
does it a little bit different
but then you find out that somebody out
there
was sneaking around the side they sort
of tunneled in a back door
and this person their code broke
and because they were sneaking through a
side door
and and
normally the attitude is
dummy um but a lot of times
um you know you can't get away you can't
you can't just slap their hand and tell
them to not do that
right because you know it's
you know somebody's
you know some banks you know account
reconciliation system
that that you know some developer
decided oh i'm lazy
you know i'll just sneak through the
back door because the language allows it
i mean you can't even right mad at them
and and so one of the things i did that
that
on the one hand upset a bunch of people
is that i made it so that
you really couldn't go through back
doors right so so the whole point of
that was to say
if you need you know if the interface
here isn't right
the wrong way to deal with that is is to
go through a back door
the right way to deal with it is to walk
up to the developer of this thing and
say
uh change the interface fix it yep
right and so it was kind of like a
social engineering thing
yeah and um it's brilliant and people
ended up
discovering that that really made a
difference
um in terms of you know and and and and
a bunch of this stuff you know
if you're just like screwing around
writing your own like you know
class project scale stuff a lot of stuff
doesn't
isn't quite so so important because
you know you're you know both sides of
the interface
um but you know when you're building
you know sort of larger more complex
pieces of software that have a lot of
people working on them
and especially when they like span
organizations
um you know having having really
clear having clarity about how that
stuff gets structured
um saves your life yeah um
and you know especially you know there's
so much software that is fundamentally
untestable
you know and you know until
you do the real thing it's better to
write
good code in the beginning as opposed to
writing crappy code and then trying to
fix it and
yeah trying to scramble and figure out
and through testing figure out where the
bugs are
yeah it's like it's like it's like
which shortcut caused that
rocket to not get where it was needed to
go
you